why don't we do why don't we do um
producer's surprise
for the last 10 minutes of this podcast
we want to do a new segment where uh you
know they pick out tick tocks and we
watch them yeah the producer's surprise
the producer surprise what this is going
to set up for those when we're in the
new studio the producer surprise is
going to evolve yes it could be a pair
of horse nuts
it's just all a horse [ __ ] Cody's like
ah
[Music]
why hey Luke and Kyle I give you
permission when we're in the new studio
to just put a horse in the studio one
day
and you know just as a surprise I would
quit the podcast
McDonald's you're walking into the
building you're just here like what the
[ __ ] is that
oh hell no
[Laughter]
all right show us what do you got show
us your yeah give us something let's see
some funny are these funny or what are
they you can see what the topics are
first one's from Kyle it just says
surfing okay I love these vague
descriptions oh is this one of the jet
ski oh no
yeah if you don't mind just taking them
with you once and then we're supposed to
go surfing together but like I said I
never got to learn and he died
oh my God
oh
my
God
dude that's oh my [ __ ] god man shout
out to Creations Ross man that guy is so
[ __ ] funny beans in the car he's the
dude who did the beans and the car oh my
God the beans and the SpaghettiOs
genius man shout out Ross Creations what
these are the best pranks like when
they're smart like this yeah
this is so smart because that kid like
felt like he owed this guy something she
take my dad with you man
go Dad
that dude just out there balancing a
[ __ ] urn just
trying to paddle through this awful
whitewash oh my God that's so funny look
at this look at the frame right there
like the wince like from his face he's
like what what huh
oh God damn it that's so good what else
we got
all right what's this one flicking a hat
racist so I'm not 100 certain if it's
racist as a white man I don't know if I
can really speak on that but I do know
it's livestock when I was a kid my
grandpa used to buy and sell sheep he
didn't raise the Sheep he just would buy
and sell he's more like a drug dealer
for sheep he would always go something
like want some sheep yep and then we
would tell the machine but one time
there was this guy that just bought one
sheep and while we were trying to unload
the sheep from the truck he kept
flicking the broom of his head like you
were doing and it was so [ __ ] weird
the guy was the weirdest person I ever
met and we drove away I was like Grandpa
why'd that guy keep looking at you and
flicking the brim of his hat like that
he goes well
what you're going to find out is in the
country there's some guys who like to
[ __ ] sheep if you're delivering a sheep
and the guy flicks the broom of his hat
like that he's asking you if you want to
[ __ ] the sheep with him so I'm not
saying you're racist but what I am
saying is every time I see one of you
[ __ ] idiots doing that I feel like
you're asking me if I want to run an
Eiffel Tower on a sheep and I don't
makes me uncomfortable I'd appreciate if
you stop asking me you do with that
information what you need to
that so the beginning which I didn't
hear you said how is flicking a hat
racist
yeah oh my God what a weird piece of
knowledge I'm Blown Away by that is that
real or was he just saying this uh
basically call the guy a sheep [ __ ]
I mean I just feel so elaborate
I can't yeah it's like too crazy to make
up
it's so specific that's where I'm like I
kind of want you know I know there's I
know we got one person you know who's
like family is like a lineage of tractor
pullers and they can go ah yeah yeah we
got a ghost seller in our family and
I'll tell you that little he [ __ ]
that sheep
a little perv that guy a little freak a
little Army Hammer with the Sheep nasty
man
oh sheep oh sheep
no no no no no all right let's see the
next one what do we got producer
surprise you don't skate
oh I love this one
they just
is so [ __ ] good and dude also how how
like unsatisfying is that uh this
doesn't that like hit that part of your
brain that's like just [ __ ] put it on
the ground and skate on it yeah it's
just running with it by this finish the
move
[Laughter]
that reminds me of our song that we used
to do on stage oh yeah yeah called the
ashes yeah we had a song I don't know
did we ever play it for the podcast I
feel like we did maybe we didn't we try
to do this like meta thing where we
would like say yeah we got a new song
and it just sounded like we just say
yeah like multiple times like like we're
about to like spit yeah we just never
say anything but I think the problem
with that live is I think people were
just so hyped that we might have done it
that no one got the joke I think it
takes like choreography or something you
know yeah we store we sort of started
doing at the end where we come together
and be like ah and then start like
walking away again
I think it could still work I think it
just needed to go longer yeah it was
like six minutes going yeah that's what
I'm talking about that's what I'm
talking about yeah no hold on I'm
getting it I'm getting there let's go
[ __ ] sound like [ __ ] up here
come on
Lady Gaga
could you help me Beyonce Don't Look
Away don't look away don't look away so
I see you there Beyonce I see you can't
you can't just put up your hand
come on now
don't look away all right let's wait
let's let's
um what else actually I think we got
some time because of the uh yeah we do a
few more do a couple more okay I didn't
know that I was old and I had absolutely
no issue with my age and then I saw a
video earlier this week on Tick Tock of
this girl who was like only the younger
generation will understand this and the
caption was 2000's babies
don't [ __ ] do that to me
I don't need a [ __ ] quarter life
crisis right now yeah my hair is damaged
and it's in a side part but I don't know
what a mortgage is you don't either what
do you want me to do shake some ass I'll
throw some ass
that was horrible anyways proof is in
the pudding I'm young and sprung out
um anyways I was like you know what
Lauren I'm confident I don't need this
um you're not old it's fine and then I
saw this video on Tick Tock of this girl
that I like have a crush on she's super
pretty super funny whatever and I was
like oh my God she posted a tick tock
and The Tick Tock was like if you use
the crying laugh Emoji this one the one
I use all the [ __ ] time uh she was
like if you use the crying laugh Emoji
you're too old for me
and I was like this is a joke so I went
to the comments and everyone was like I
would rather [ __ ] die than speak to
someone who uses the crying laugh Emoji
what I will hurl myself through a window
is that what you [ __ ] want
I'm 25. you see this is a problem with
these with these ones it's when people
are complaining about people complaining
about the younger generation and they're
still younger than us you know what I'm
saying
yeah I mean I have a tick tock now is
people complaining about the fact that
people that are born in 2000 are 21 now
and they're 25 it's like you're still
you're the exact same age yeah I just
think what's
lgbtq
what what does that have to do anything
[Laughter]
I don't know
um nah I think what's you know I feel
bad for Laura Steele here because you
should have known that the crying laugh
Emoji was like Boomer [ __ ] crying laugh
Emoji went transcended to meta in like
20
14. yeah it was already like an ironic
yeah it it started getting [ __ ] up
when people started baking it into their
like Instagram they're like Instagram
captions that are baked into the video
yeah like when these are the white bars
yeah yeah that's when the crying
laughing emoji died yeah that's when it
stops meaning what it means what it's
supposed to mean
it was intended to mean like oh man
Laura still if you see this um you need
to head over to old head memes on uh on
Instagram and see that literally every
post uses a crying laugh emotion I'm
sorry to break it to you
laughs all right we got one more let's
do one more
what the [ __ ] is this
wait is there music or don't forget to
sparkle and shine today and remember if
anyone tries to dull your sparkle
they're just jealous
what I can't tell if she's 70 or 7.
or 77.
yeah do you hashtag she hashtag the
bimbo Tick Tock it's bimbo tick tock
yo that's so funny man people oh man
bimbo Tick Tock that's that's a [ __ ]
Boomer ass word right there bimbo bimbo
was like that was that was um the
political term for hoe yeah like 30
years ago yeah that was hussy too
yeah us no I think people
oh yeah hussy yeah hussy's old yeah
bro
oh my God it's so funny to be on Tick
Tock to be like a proud like bimbo
that was such a diss back in the day you
[ __ ] bimbo
this is these are the this is how she
hashtagged it hashtag hashtag Chanel
addict hashtag you should know hashtag
accountant
bimbo Tick Tock hashtag Gucci gang
Barbie batch block out the noise Barbie
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] secular she threw
accountant in there randomly yeah just
yeah by the way I do have a job
but I'm also a [ __ ] hussy
glitter Paris Ginger
look look go to her whole page is that
the whole page it's like glitter shine
positivity posts oh yeah oh Lord
oh my god oh we gotta
yeah no we won't we won't you know we
don't know what's going on here but yeah
Chanel West Coast and glitter glitter
pairs Ginger about to have their own
celebrity boxing match
oh man